this dish doesn't get a nice reaction
from gordon ramsay okay
let's go big boy show me what you got
just made a new mcdonald's
seriously to make this toasty we put oh
cheese i
love pumpkin pie let's go
no no no no
[Music]
rosie what's happened to you man all
right okay
big chuck flavor train let's jump on
board and ride with your big boy
let's go five and a half hours great
color smoke
lightly flavors now already i can smell
it from here big man
okay good the toughest burger on the
planet to get right
okay brushing seasoning with cocktail
sticks
hold on performing acupuncture on a
chicken you're supposed to cook it not
prick it
it's all if you know you know absolutely
seasoning well sergeant gilbert
dc marvel lights here here the other
side
same pan shallots garlic okay classic
garlic sauce
[Music]
by the way
okay good flavor in there
potato icing oh for god's sake man
keep it moist
[Music]
you can't do that to mozzarella steak
it's gonna be like a mouthful of sugar
don't put that foil away keep the foil
don't squeeze too hard oh you're
squeezing all the juice out man
big chuck the train's gone
[Music]
three and a half hours later kill the
heat however 40 minutes in the liquid
time beef
short ribs wow now you're talking about
heirloom carrot and turkey what the hell
why are you playing connect four with
those carrots where are the original
carrots
cooked for two and a half hours the
carrots with the flavor your
for the love of god please blow this
post show me your carrots
and then marshmallow sauce what's that
no liquid marshmallow no
you boys need to get back to school
quickly what the hell are you doing
making a cake out of a steak
wedding cake that should be server the
divorce proceeding is your donut
what's happened to you kid